So many people have asked me what a tribewife is like,
what makes it different from somebody like me
who's like a stay at home mom or traditional homemaker.
And I think I finally come up with like a couple of qualifiers
because not every homesteading account is a tribewife account.
Not every home making or stay at home mom account
is a tribewife account.
Starting off they have to be a stay at home mom or homemaker.
But not just that,
they have to believe that that is the natural given role for women.
Number two is the aesthetic.
Trad wives dress femininely,
wear dresses, have makeup on,
are not like the hot mess mom archetype.
They are the polished and put together mom again
because that is the image that they believe
women should be portraying.
Number three is like the religious undertones.
These women look at traditional homemaking as an offshoot
of their religious morality.
And a lot of this gets wrapped up also with like purity culture.
And I wanna make another video on that
cause that's where the pipeline is.
And then class.
Most trad wife accounts are middle class or higher.
There's a lot to unpack there.